wait here for half an hour you've got
your knighthood how do you feel it feels
absolutely marvelous I feel absolutely
great I thought I'd finished all the
interviews but you're very pushing
getting to because I'm putty in your
hands I'm doing it but sky I'll do
anything the sky because one of my
daughter's works the sky so I've got to
turn okay so take as much time as your
master Bruce just time we might finish
on a song okay that's fine you can leave
on tell me what up what what did Her
Majesty say to you Her Majesty asked me
how long I'd been in showbiz she said
you've been entertaining us a long time
she said well how long I said well you
know coming up next year I'll have been
in show business seventy years which did
shocker and then then she said well when
did you stop I said when I was 14 that
shocked her again that I was but in the
war you see schoolchildren you could
leave when you were 14 years of age and
go into making parachutes or things for
the to help the war effort but I wit I
didn't do it here there I went ready to
show business worked around all the
dumps that we had in this country the
lousy theatres that I trudged round
OD'ing practically nothing I think my
first first week's work I've got 34
pence that was it so it's been a long
time but it's been wonderful this is the
ultimate and hold up for us there we are
there it is okay and it feels so great
why did it take so much grateful why did
it take so long I don't know it's I
think it's something to do with maybe
light entertainment but I'm hoping that
this will forward for people I mean
people like the Two Ronnies never got it
more from a wise never got it Frankie
how is it Tommy Cooper you can go back
so why shouldn't run E here yeah Jimmy
Tarbuck Eric Sykes all these people I've
I think they're worthy and comedy is a
is a hard job you know it's not it's not
like this a building labor but we do
have mental things that we have to put
up with and is trying to get a hot laugh
is sometimes much harder than doing a
straight line tell me modern comedians I
thought you said that's gonna be quick
it nearly is fair with me come on
modern comedians they use a lot of
language in their variation without a
family man this is why I still work
although people complain about me maybe
and say in mind
my jokes are a bit corny maybe they
think they're all but I work on a family
level I always have done for 70 years
I've worked in a family level and I've -
they're edgy and squaring you promised
us a song no I did you can see back to
the studio you're a star I feel like I
should bow down right